in the future I promised Meza but I'll
do the best I can to fulfill the dreams
that we shared myself and my roommate's
my friends my boyfriend we had so many
dreams so I'll work to make sure that
all the dreams that we shed I achieve
them
he asked if there are other people in
the room but Elizabeth I really treasure
her she died as a mater and never
rebuild that there were other people in
the room
remember when they came that they
started with a Christian who had gone to
fellowship in the morning so I usually
imagine suppose that happens so that
results why I live in here's when at any
Christian who knows sometimes it is hard
to forget that thing we've been trying
to forget it but at times just find
yourself in a nightmare just find
yourself probably in Garissa through
dreams you find yourself maneuvering
through the cool tools and trying to
imagine how you you you could have saved
yourself supposes profound you in a
hostile you know that thing is not going
away from us